herzlich willkommen zum Q&A von me
Reportage abzock auf only Fans wie
Männer von Chat manipuliert werden als
allererst muss ich sagen riesen Merc für
die Resonanz auf das Video es ist n
spannend wie wie die meinige teilin g
also fast zwei Lager aufteil die einte
wo wirklich Mitleid mit dem Mner h und
den andere Lager einfach find hey ne
sorry die Männer sind so V selber schuld
die me abzieh bis auf der let sent Mal
sogar geschrieben ich selber find man
das einfach nicht so einfach sagen ich
hab ja selber undercover Chatter of only
Fans geschaffet ich hab HU Nachricht be
und der Hufe von den Nachrichten sind
wirklich grusig sind respektlos gie sind
auch degradierende Frau gagenüber gie
und da ist es den mega einfach zum sagen
ja die H nicht anders verdient aber ich
ich selber frage mich wieso schrieb ihr
überhaupt so also es muss ja ein Grund g
dass man sicher so verhaltet also ganz
abgesehen DAV oder dass man einfach auf
die Plattform GT und sine sexuelle lustw
befriedige aber das wo ich selber
gemerkt habe ist das da no teils wieis
unterliegend ist und da vielleicht auch
gerade die erste Frage zu von mil FI wo
mich fragt wie es mir gangen ist als mal
also kannst du es selber nachvollziehen
warum me Mann dafür Geld zahlt ist es
nur das Ausleben von Fantasien live oder
weil man eine gewisse Macht über die
Frau hat weil sie vermeintlich das tut
was der Mann möchte ich kann es
nachvollziehen wieom für servis Geld
zahl ich glaub ist mischigus all drü
Punkt ein große Teil ist natürlich
einfach klar die mit die wen die die
sexuelle Lust befriedigen okay aber denn
glaube ich gibt's auch ein Teil und das
hab ich zumindest so gemerkt dass dir
nch such dass dir unsich sind also drum
such weil Sie unsicher sind weil sie
vielleicht kein erfolgch Frau sozial
isoliert sind und sich so Stück
Intimität Kauf und denn gerade bin Frau
sie vielleicht speziell attraktiv findet
kauf sie sich a eine Stück Exklusivität
also dass S sich selber sag ich schriebe
jetzt mit der so nur größere EG
Bestätigung und die Exklusivität wird ja
in Chats und von Models aktiv beworbe
dass man der content jetzt für deremacht
H und letztlich bezüglich Punkt macht
das ist das interessant Stichwort weil
ich glaube es ist tatsächlich so dass
das auch Rolle spielt dass man sich so
Stück macht kauft aber ich kann als
Chatter ganz klar wiesig be dass ich
jeder Unterhaltig muss Oberhand palte
weil viele m auch gar h wenn sie so
unterordnet W dass sie gerar unterwürfig
sind und bewusst mit dem mus Spiel und
dann Kommentar
der 7 m W so g zah definitiv Kontrolle
verloren und wür Therapie investieren
und da frage ich mich selber ist das was
sie macht mit deer Models Chat nicht
auch wie Therapie für sie gerade jetzt
der letzte Typ mit dem ich geschrieben
nachd da sexuelle Fantasie da befriedigt
ich mit ih recht lang geschrieben über
verzählt was sieine Hobbys sind was er
gern macht aber wie allem W geschrieben
hat gesagt ja ich weiß es den Mega
langwillig und ja ich bin ein Loser und
ich kan kein Kollege und er hat wirklich
so schlecht über sich selber geschrieben
und halt das Chat mit dem Model ihm
quses Gefühl von zehörigkeit G und
gerade für so was so sozial isoliert
sind wo so wenig Höch von sich selber
danket ist der Schritt zu mit Therapie
einfach so ein große und das ma jetzt
nicht einfach so obwohl es logisch wie
der viel nachhaltigere Schritt war denn
die nächste Frage von akranier es wird
ständig von Ethik und Moral gesprochen
ist es nicht strafrechtlich ein Betrug
meiner Meinung nach verstößt es ganz
klar gegen das
Strafgesetzbuch schwierig weil moralisch
geseh ist es ganz klar betrug aber wil
der ma ja war beund also s Bilder und
Videos für dir zahlt h ist es kein
Straftat und Punkt ich mit dem Paul von
der Schwizer Agentur besprochen für alle
beteiligt win win win aber für me
Geschmack der Moral
schlussendlich Jain ich glaub
schlich
Konsument Ziel ja Cont oder vielleicht
jaüber und das Ziel grundslich erreicht
wer natürlich her sch ich wüns mir das
Video wo so und so und noch meh von dem
und nimmt das und ja das Video über wo
sich vorgestellt hat
und ja genau schwierig zum sag also drum
kann man nicht sag verarschig Konsum das
über w er W absolut
absolut nicht ganz richtig so also
Überbringer nacher anders so ja ich
glaub
nachfr ich WN
ich
onl ch mit dir ich
WE
dasasmin
bendlich mit mir ich frag zu Produkt der
sag mir du mus das so zurüchicken
verpack ich für
mich fr bist du wirklich zeig
mal Ziel ich produktier und wer mir das
zT ist mir eigentlich
egal Frage wem gehört der Content
schllich gehört Agentur oder geh Model
der Paul h mir selber gesag D B Agentur
so ist dass jeglicher Content am Model
gehört von der Mira wiederum ich gehört
dass sie V Vertrag gehört h das genau
anders also D jeglicher Content der
Agentur gehört und da gibt's ganz sicher
große Unterschied zwischen der Agentur
klar ist aber wenn man kein Agentur hat
ist man selber Urheberin vom Content
aber das schützt halt auch nicht vor
Betrug weil es ist recht einfach zum
einfach ein Screenshot machen oder
Screen recording vom Content das
irgendwie auf der Website lad und so
wird dann wie verbreitet und obwohl
aktiv g Vorgang wird was halt im
Internet ist blibt für immer im Internet
n das passt gerade zu der nche frag von
webit 1708 was mich aber auch
interessieren würde wie sieht es für die
Models aus werden diese von Agenturen
ausgenutzt oder sind die Angebote fair
was mir aber Mira git und was ich
selbercherche gefunden ist dass es rcht
viel schwarze Schaf unter der Agentur
geht die Schwizer Agentur z.B hät es
selber auch gesag dass oftmals Models zu
ih wo das so letzte Chance Z mit Agentur
schaffen einfach so komische
geschichteit wie z.B das Model a eigen
accountüt worden ist oder D Agentur
Screenshots gefaked und viel wenig
zurücküberwies und der
grö also da gibt ganze HU so Geschichte
und dann so paar Kommentar so richtig K
g
wie was noch komplett fehlt bei dieser
Reportage wie sieht es mit KI in diesem
Bereich aus die wird sicherlich schon
genutzt für die erzeug von Bild Sowi
Text dazu mus ich sag dass ich ganz
bewusst derpekt KI einfach weil das
selber sich Ries Fass ist W ich nicht no
aufmachen kurz Gesit kann man sagen das
K mittelw immer mehresetzt wird also
dass es auch
Fans Profil GT mit nur KI generierte
Bilder von Frau wo gar nicht a sind was
Texte mit mirag immer mehr so KI basier
die Tools creatf zurückri zum der
zurückschrieben aber das ist definitiv
in der nächste 3 4 5 6 Jahr wird das
Ries W den da der Lom hfagt wieso mir oh
bezahliges Interview gemacht gerade im
hblick auf die prekare Situation von der
Chatterin Verst ganz fest wieso komisch
mag über dass mir Chatterin wo nicht
viel verdient oder tendenziell so sch
dass sie ausbütet wird nicht nur exra
zahlt für das Interview aber es ist
einfach ganz einfach dass mir nie für
das Interview zahlet und einfach zum die
journalistische Unabhängigkeit war D mir
einfach niis für das Interview g den
jetzt nur frag vom Simon emarent wo
fragt würde Robin weiblichen Personen
welche wichtig sind empfehlen deren
Partnersuche auf die Fans zu starten
definitiv nicht aber ich verstah V wor
fragkund es h be vielen Nachrichten W
ich be so ein Unterton ich w dich
treffen wie kann ich dich treffen ich
würde dich so gerne jetzt treffen we den
würde ich das mit dir machen also das
das schwingt glaub all Nachrichten mit
dass man so Gefühl h dass dass man jetzt
dass dass ich jetzt D bin wo dir Frau
aus der virtuelle weltholt und sie
richtig kan treffe also ich glaub genau
fangt aber so die persönlich bezieh dass
man das halt auch wirklich auch wenn man
das weiß das GT nicht man hät trotzdem
irgendwie das Gefühl dass es irgendwie
könt g aber Partner Fans das ich
definitiv n nie gehört und würde ich
absolut nicht Fall und den die letzte
Frage wieder vom akranier warum hat
dieses Video keine
Altersbeschränkung ganz einfach es sind
kein pornographische Inhalts ges und
ist wichtig sie zum Realität wirklich so
abbildde wie sie auch wirklich so
stattfindet das wie Argument ist wenn
man so eine triggerw am Anfang vom Video
tut dass es aber genau gerade denn ein
Reiz für und 18 ist zum das Video l das
war V Q&A mer mal für und L und bis zum
nächsten Mal